Bill what you do you have a game Sunday
and you come and you look at the videos
and you look at the mistakes made and
you analyze the mistakes made and how to
get
better
right yes we we do an assessment after
every game we do an assessment an
assessment after each period in the year
so free agency the offseason program the
draft mini camps things like that um and
and the idea is really to look at what
we did well and and what caused that
what we didn't do well and what caused
that what decisions were critical
decisions and you know how those turned
out and was there a flaw in the process
or maybe a process helped us make the
right decision depending on how it went
um and what were the critical errors
what caused the critical errors in the
game a critical penalty a critical
mental error or critical Communication
Breakdown whatever it was um and we do
that winterly lose doesn't it doesn't
matter like the evaluation is the
evaluation um what we would do
differently you know if we face this
opponent again or opponent with a
similar
um similar type Personnel or Sim similar
scheme how we and so just a full
evaluation of everything that happened
with the idea of you know making that
better and not having the same thing
next week on this on that sheet you know
not saying the same thing was the same
mistake we made last week the same
mistake we made last this another
communic same communication mistake and
try to eliminate those and and you know
continue to correct things and recognize
what we did well why did we win what did
we do well to win all right let's make
sure that we continue to emphasize and
do that because that's that's the reason
why we won um so it's not just
eliminating mistakes it's also trying to
build into your strengths and you know
it's really pretty pretty basic of you
know any war or any counter you know use
your strengths and and don't let your
weaknesses you know bring you down so
play play to your strengths and and
protect your
weaknesses